over the course of three seasons the
title character of the Mandalorian has
gone from Ruthless Bounty Hunter to
Bonafide Galactic hero and a dad to boot
here's how he got there
in the third season the Mandalorian
flashes back to grogu's early days in
the Jedi Temple more specifically it's
one Very Bad Day when Order 66 occurs
grogu barely makes it off of Coruscant
alive after Darth Vader and his Clone
Army attacked the Jedi Revenge of the
Sith takes place almost 30 years before
the Mandalorian which would make grogu
around 20 during his Escape he needs the
help of many allies to get away in one
piece numerous Jedis sacrificed their
lives to get grogu out he's eventually
intercepted by Master Keller and Beck
played by Ahmed bass he also voiced and
did the motion capture for Jar Jar Binks
Kellerman Bank successfully fights off
the advancing clones and takes grogu on
a 10-speed to chase through Coruscant
arriving at a landing pad where a Naboo
ship is ducked a group of guards helps
keep the Clone forces at Bay while
Keller run and grogu make their getaway
in the ship this flashback raises as
many questions as it answers how did
grogu come to be in the Jedi Temple in
the first place where was he for the 30
years between his escape and when din
jarin found him that pad Mason and the
Naboo Gods to help him and what became
of Kellerman Beck hopefully we'll find
out more about grogu's past soon
long before he was a bounty hunter who
honored the traditions of Mandalore
dinjarin the titular Mandalorian was a
young boy who lived on the planet Arc
vertina during the age of the old
Galactic Republic din's Home is attacked
by combat droids from the separatist
Confederacy so his parents hide him in a
small bunker shortly before they're
killed in the massacre Dennis eventually
discovered by a hostile Droid but is
saved as a Mandalorian group known as
Death Watch descend into the fight this
faction of mandalorians would eventually
separate into warring factions one of
which came to be known for their
fanatical and shrinked at heroines to
ancient Traditions the children of the
watch one of the death watch members
helps Den out of his hiding space and
whisks him to safety Dinner becomes a
foundling abandon the lone children
saved and adopted by mandalorians the
Clone Wars and Star Wars Rebels detail
the gradual decline of Mandalore from a
strong Galactic power to a desperate
Imperial Colony ages of infighting have
led to division and weakness within the
once powerful society which made it easy
for Emperor Palpatine and his armies to
subjugate Rebel shows how Bogota
increase led her people in resistance
but the Mandalorian reveals the sad
results of her actions the Great Purge
of Mandalore
Bo Katan is a cautionary Tale a night of
a thousand tears was the initiating
event of The Purge it was a brutal
Imperial campaign that wiped out
Mandalorian military units and civilian
targets alike huge swabs of the
Mandalorian Homeworld were devastated
prompting bogatan to broke a piece with
moth Gideon she relinquished the
darksaber the symbol of ruling power on
Mandalore to him in exchange for a
guarantee of safety for mandalore's
citizens of course Gideon went back on
the deal and continued his genocidal
attacks on the planet the few survivors
were forced to live in hiding or go on
the runner's Mercenaries
the Mandalorian depicts the early years
of New Republic Rule and the beginning
of the secret Imperial Remnant that
eventually leads to the rise of the
first order most of this happens on the
background but there are moments when we
get a better look at what's actually
going on in the shadows throughout the
series so far moth Gideon has grappled
with a secret cloning project that's not
fully revealed until the end of the
third season he needs grogu to help
develop the force sensitive parts of the
project at the same time other former
Imperials are building strengthen other
areas as explored in the aftermath
novels many of Palpatine's most loyal
followers have Retreats it to the
unknown regions after the battle of
jakku these expats become the foundation
of what becomes a first order Gideon's
secret base on Mandalore is also likely
constructed during this time or even
earlier it's far too complex have been
built entirely after his Escape From The
Republic custody but it's unclear how
long he stayed dealt the great Forge
five years after the fall of the Empire
on the planet Navarro dinner's grown up
to be a seasoned Bounty Hunter he works
for grief cargo an agent of the Bounty
Hunter's Guild and accepts Targets on a
contract basis early on cargo maintains
connections with the remaining Imperials
but it seems to be good for business he
even attempts to pay Den in Imperial
currency but the Bounty Hunter rejects
our form of payment I don't know if you
heard but the Empire is gone cargo
offers Den the Bounty that will change
his life forever after meeting with an
imperial client Den learns his targets
as to be captured Alive or Dead with the
latter option garnering a lower fee it's
also revealed that the target is
approximately 50 years old it's a rather
mysterious proposition but din takes it
on without hesitation
dinner arrives in Avala 7 to track down
the Target and he is instantly assaulted
by its Wildlife he's saved by quill an
upright agnor who recently gained his
freedom after spending his life in
servitude
shows dinner to ride a monstrous
creature called a blurk so Dinka made
the Trek to the encumbent where his
Target resides as din spies on the
incumbent he sees another Bounty Hunter
the Droid ig-11 engaged the hostiles on
the ground Mando teams up with the Droid
to secure the Bounty grogu who is of the
same species as Master Yoda and yado
Mando is confused by the target's youth
but ig-11 notes that varying aliens age
at different rates ig-11 then aims to
collect the Bounty but din terminates
the Droid before the child can be harmed
it experiences a child's force abilities
for the first time when it saves his
life from a mud horn even after that
encounter Jim reluctantly returns a
child to his Imperial client
then soon has second thoughts however
and he retrieves grogu with the help of
his fellow mandalorians
din escapes with grogu in tow and is
determined to flee far away from the
grasp of the Bounty Hunter's Guild
knowing full well that they have
trackers capable of locating the child
they'd land on the planet sorghum where
they meet Kiera Dune an ex-rebel shop
Trooper din learns that the village he's
visiting is being tormented by Raiders
he accepts an offer to help with the
assistance of Dune in exchange for a
temporary roof over his head many of the
villagers have lost loved ones to the
Raiders so DIN and dune train them to
defend themselves they successfully
repel a Raider incursion even though the
enemy force is packing an imperial atst
Jim resolves to leave the child at the
Village to live in peace but Kara Doon
narrowly saves her child's life after
she terminates a bounty hunter sniper
from the trees knowing it is no longer
safe on sorghun it didn't leaves with
the child another Bounty Hunter soon
pursues DIN and Grogan then manages to
outmaneuver his pursuer but to ship the
razor Crest is damaged he lands in MOS
Eisley on Tatooine for repairs leaving
the child in the care of the repair shop
manager of palimoto Mando sets off to
find work to pay for the repairs he
comes across a young and inexperienced
Bounty Hunter Toro kalikan who is
attempting to get into the Bounty
Hunter's Guild by accepting a rather
tough assignment hunting down the
Assassin fenik Shan kalakan and Les
din's helped to find Shan after a 10
Showdown that leads to Shan's capture
Chanda tells kalakan that the
Mandalorian and the child are high value
targets of the guild and that killing
the Mandalorian would bring color can
Fame and the legendary status talakan
shoots Shand but doesn't kill her he
then takes a child in Moto captive then
arrives and kills a young Bounty Hunter
using kaliken's money to pay Moto for
the repairs before departing Tatooine
seeking more work ding contacts an old
friend ranzar maalk who offers him a job
that requires a team of five spring a
prisoner from a new Republic prison the
other members of the team include an
ex-imperial Sharpshooter named mix
mayfeld a devaronian a Droid and a
Twilight woman named Xi'an with whom din
shares a history tensions Run High in
the group din distrust the others and
they seem largely contemptuous of him
yet they successfully free The Prisoner
who turns out to be shion's brother
Quinn he was imprisoned after din left
him behind on a previous Mission the
others turn on dinner locking him in
Quinn's prison cell then manages to
escape him begins hunting down his
former teammates one by one after
defeating and imprisoning each of them
he delivers Quinn to Mulk himself
demanding his payment before taking off
Mao quarters as gunship Pilots to shoot
din down but realizes with horror that
didn't place the Homing beacon on Quinn
three new Republic X-Wing Fighters
arrive and attack Mark station
then soon receives a message from grief
kaga asking for his assistance in taking
down Imperial troops that have seized
his City on Navarro kaga says the
operation will wipe the mysterious
client who seeks a child off the board
I would like to see the baby plus cargo
will clear din's name with the guild
which would mean the Mandalorian could
continue traveling with grogu didn't
reluctantly accepts in hopes of removing
the constant danger of bounty hunters on
his Trail he also recruits Cara Dune to
assist with the operation DIN and dune
made contact with quill and find that he
has restored ig-11 but installed
programming that has enabled it to learn
from his experience and gain a new
caring personality Quail suggests that
he care for the child alongside ig-11
while DIN and dune carry out their
mission Dan who hates droids because of
the events of his youth on akovatina the
voices his distress of ig-11 but agrees
it's revealed that cargo have planned to
betrayed Ian but he drops his plot after
the child heals him from a near fatal
wound din hatch is a plan to pose as
kaga and dunes prisoner to reach the
client meanwhile Stormtroopers find and
kill quill and take the child
din's plan might have worked if not for
the arrival of moff Gideon whose troops
kill the clients of pin down din Dune
and kaga thankfully ig-11 finds a
stormtrooper to captured grogu and takes
him back he then rides a Speeder Bike
through town eliminating Stormtroopers
giving DIN and the others the
distraction they need to start fighting
din is injured in the fighting and the
group retreats to The Cantina where
they'd met the client din tells cargo
and dune to escape through the sewers
with grogu and seek help from the
mandalorians
ig11 officer Hill din but din initially
refuses to remove his helmet because of
the children of the watch's code of
honor ig11 insists it's not a living
being so removing the helmet shouldn't
be a violation din reluctantly removes
his helmet so ig-11 can heal him with a
bag to spray didn't ig-11 follow their
friends into the tunnels only to find
out that most of the Mandalorian
Warriors who resided there have fled the
yamara who stayed behind to collect
their materials declares that DIN and
the child are now Clan mudhorn she
explains that din's new directive is to
keep the child as a foundling until he
can be returned to his own people din
kaga Dune ig-11 and grogu then flee on a
boat down a Lava River ig-11 sacrifices
himself to destroy their pursuers and
din takes down moff Gideon's TIE fighter
believing Gideon to be dead the heroes
go their separate ways a surviving
Gideon cursed his way out of the
wreckage with a fabled dark saber
Tim begins searching for other
mandalorians to Aid him in his quest to
return the child to his people and the
learns of a Mandalorian in Moss pelgo on
Tatooine there Den meets sheriff cop
Vamp who is adorned and a particularly
distinctive set of Mandalorian armor
Boba Fett's not a Mandalorian himself
vantha claims have purchased it from a
group of Jowers but around here
I'm the one tells folks what to do
didn't the manziama back but before they
can fight over it the town is struck by
a crate dragon that has been facing on
the local livestock vanth agrees to give
din the armor if they work together to
slay the dragon the pair works with a
Town's folk as well as a group of Tuscan
Raiders who also want the crate Dragon
dead then eventually tricks the creature
into swallowing Kim and his bantha which
is packing explosives he escapes by
Shocking the creature flies from the
crate dragon's mouth and detonates the
explosives saving the town from the
creature and winning Boba Fett's armor
din heads back to Moss Eisley in hopes
of finding another lead to track down
other mandalorians harimoto puts him in
touch with the Frog lady who requires
that didn't take her along with her eggs
to a moon called Trask he is also not
allowed to use his hyperdrive or her
eggs will die while on Roots the razor
Crest has flanked by two new Republic
x-wings which recognize a razor Crest as
a craft involved in the earlier Prison
Break dim manages to evade the x-wings
but in the process crash lands at an ice
Canyon on a remote Planet didn't make
some necessary repairs but he grogu and
the Frog lady are swarmed by spider-like
creatures the new Republic X-Wing
Fighters arrive to save the day they
know that Dean has an arrest warrant for
breaking Quinn House of prison but they
also note that he detained three others
with warrants and rest his life trying
to save a new Republic officer
upon arriving on Trask and despite
grogu's appetite for her eggs the Frog
lady informs din of an inn where
mandalorians have been spotted a fish
boat captain tells Mando that he knows
what a mandalorians are and can take him
there but the captain attempts to kill
Dan and grogu so that he can steal din's
best car armor a group of mandalorians
arrive inside the duo but then remove
their helmets which instantly puzzles
din the leader Bo Katan explains that as
a child of the watch dinners are
religious fanatic she however is part of
a mainstream Society born on Mandalore
which apparently tolerates helmet
removal despite din's initial distress
of Boca town he eventually aligns with
her team Boca Town agrees to assist dim
with the grogu if he helps her raid an
imperial freighter during the mission
she reveals that she is searching for
the darksaber which she believes she
needs to rule Mandalore once again after
they take the ship bokotan tells them
where he can find a Jedi named Ahsoka
tono then heads back to Navarro where he
meets up with Kara Dune and grief kaga
Dune is now serving as a local martial
and kaga is high magistrate cargo
arranges for the complete repair of the
razor Crest and that's then to help take
out her remaining Imperial base in an
effort to bring peace to Navarro din
Dune cargo and the mithril that din
captured for cargo earlier learned at
the base of the research facility full
of cloned bodies a recording from Dr
perching who is overseeing Gideon's
clothing experiments indicates that
during the brief time they had access to
the child Imperial researchers have been
attempting to transfuse his blood into
the Clones the recording also reveals
that moff Gideon is still alive the team
arranges for the basis destruction of
fleeing enemy forces ultimately
prevailing thanks to a repaired Razer
Crest DIN and grogu leave to find Ahsoka
while Dune and cargo deal with New
Republic investigators it's revealed
that one of cargo's mechanics was
planted a tracking beacon on the Razer
Crest on Gideon's behalf
on the forest planet's corvus Ahsoka
gives Imperial magistrate Morgan Elle's
birth and ultimatum surrender and
identify the whereabouts of her master
Grand Admiral thrawn or die didn't
arrives in a magistrate City hello Dan
and meets with her she offers him a
Bhaskar sphere if he kills Ahsoka
outside the city Ahsoka ambushes din but
stops attacking when he tells her that
he was sent by Boca turn Ahsoka
communicates with the child and learns
that he hails from coruscant's Jedi
Temple as well as his name grogu his
head in his abilities to survive over
the years
Ahsoka tells them that she cannot train
grogu due to the child's anger and fear
and his attachment to den in exchange
for Ahsoka helping him obtain Jedi
training for grogu then offers to help
Ahsoka take down Elle's birth the pear
storm kaladan where Mando kills a
magistrates Lieutenant while Ahsoka
confronts the magistrate herself the
Jedi defeats El's Beth and demands to
know where thrawn is dead meanwhile
claims the best gas fear after the
victory Ahsoka still refuses to train
grogu instructing din to take him to the
planet's tython where he can set grow
grew Upon A seeing Stone Within the
Ruins of the Jedi Temple and the desired
can attempt to call the Jedi using the
force
and python Kroger communes with the
force but Boba Fett interrupts with
Fenix Shands by his side feds saved her
life after her encounter with Toro
kalakan and the two of them have been
tracking din to obtain the armor that he
recovered from cobwanth then agrees to
give fed the armor but only if he helps
protect the child as Imperial forces
arrive din fat and Shand all engaged the
encroaching Stormtroopers or grogu
continues to meditate just when it seems
like Victory is in hand moth Gideon who
has been watching from a cruiser
destroys the razor Crest and unleashes
his dark Troopers they capture the
drained grogu and take him away for
further experimentation that and Shand
agreed to stick with din until grogu was
rescued
Mando returns to Navarro and ask Hera
Dune to use their position as martial to
temporarily release a former Imperial he
worked with during the prison break
makes Mayfield to help track moff Gideon
mayfell's Imperial clearances still gain
him the access he needs to obtain the
coordinates of Gideon's ship Mayfield
reveals that there is a secluded
Imperial rydonium Refinery located in
the heart of the planet morak after
arriving at morak dinner mayfeld
disguised himself as Imperials and
deliver a shipment of rhydonium to the
facility inside din shows just how much
he cares for grogu by willingly removing
his helmet to keep up the ruse allowing
living creatures to see his face dinner
May Felder approached by Officer Valen
Hess who forces them into having a drink
the officer disrespects Imperial
soldiers who died during operation
Cinder a disastrous campaign that
mayfaeld experienced personally angered
by the callousness of his former
Superior mayfeld shoots Hess forcing he
and din to fight their way out to the
facility while Dune and Shand provide
cover fire as they flee on fat ship
Mayfield shoots a cache of explosive
vidonium destroying the factory for his
help Dune sets Mayfield free
didn't Kara Doom managed to board an
imperial ship and take Dr Pershing
hostage later Fitz and din track down
Boca town and casca Reeves seeking their
help to rescue grogu Boca time agrees to
help as long as she can kill moff Gideon
and take the darksaber the group finds
and Boards Gideon's ship Gideon Alicia's
Dark Trooper droids which are nearly
indestructible however din discovers
that the best gar spear can pierce the
armor he traps several and ejects him
out of an airlock didn't confronts
Gideon fighting off his darksaber with
the best gas fear din ultimately defeats
the moth and brings him to the bridge
along with grogu their Gideon attempts
to pit Boca tan against din who
rightfully earned the darksaber in the
fight Mando tries to give Boca San the
darksaber the weapon can't be given only
one in combat before all of this can
come to head however the dark Troopers
have been blasted into space returned to
Gideon's ship and begin to March toward
the bridge ripping apart any obstacles
in their path all hope scenes lasted a
dark Troopers start to butter down the
door to the bridge just then however a
single mysterious X-Wing arrives and
Ducks a cloud figure boards the craft
and begins eliminating dark Troopers
moth Gideon realizes there is no longer
any way out of his predicament and
attempts to kill the child and then
himself but didn't defends a child and
Cara Dune disables Gideon knocking him
unconscious when the doors finally open
all the dark Troopers have been
destroyed and the cloaked figure is
revealed to be none other than Luke
Skywalker he heard grogu's call from
tython and has come to offer him the
training he needs grogu doesn't want to
leave a surrogate father but didn't
insist that it's for the best in an
emotional farewell dinner again goes
against ancient Mandalorian tradition
removing his helmet and showing grogu
his face Luke vows to protect the child
while Den promise says that one day he
and Kroger will see each other again
seemingly back to his old ways of the
Bounty Hunter then his next scene
tracking a new Target by the name of
Kaaba bias when kaaba's goons
surrounding he slices his enemies to
bits using the darksaber he then bisects
biasma moves his head as proof of the
kill he delivers the bounty in exchange
to the location of the new Hideout of
the children of the watch didn't look
Casey Amara along with parts Vizsla one
of din's Rivals within the covert the
armor right inspects the darksaber and
confirms that winning it in combat
grants the wielder leadership of
Mandalore She also asked in for the best
guard spear so that it can be shaped
into armor she explains that and
DeLorean steel is meant for armor not
weapons didn't requests let it be made
into armor for Grogan Paul's vizsler
challenges Mando to a door to win the
darksaber from him because the blade was
forged by vizsla's ancestor din wins but
when he reveals that he has removed his
helmet the armorer declares him a
Mandalorian no more
with the Razer Crest now a heap of scrap
metal din sets out to retrieve a new
ship he receives a message from Pele
Moto indicating that she has a
replacement for him so din heads to
Tatooine Moto has an N1 Starfighter from
the boo that has clearly seen better
days dim reluctantly agrees to help her
finish restoring it and add new
modifications along the way after a lot
of work dinners are very fast and
battle-ready new ship he proclaims over
the Roar of the engine that's a lot of
engine for a little ship after a
successful flight test din is ready for
his next adventure
while Daniel's working on his new ride
Boba Fett and fennekshand have taken
over the Tatooine criminal Empire
formally controlled by Jabba the hurt
their rule is shaky however and they
find themselves up against the mayor of
moss esper and the pike Syndicate in
need of allies Shanta comes to din who
agrees to help free of charge but he has
to make a quick stop first din heads to
a remote Forest planet where he finds
Luke Skywalker's droids constructing a
Jedi score he also finds Ahsoka who
warns them to avoid distracting his
former fondling from his Jedi training
didn't leaves Yama made from the best
garpia with Ahsoka and departs Luke
meanwhile senses that grogu's heart is
not fully invested in his Jedi training
he offers grogu a choice received the
armor left for him and return to his
former caretaker or continue his
training and receive a lightsaber din
heads to Moss pelgo now known as
Freetown overseen by kovanth who is now
a martial vant has taken a stand against
the pike Syndicate and then asks him to
consider an alliance after din leaves a
cad bane of Bounty Hunter previously
seen in the animated Clone Wars series
shoots van from the martial refuses to
make a deal with him dim returns to
Moses bird and finds a pike Syndicate
already closing in even worse the other
criminal leaders of Tatooine have turned
on Fett and ambushed his allies despite
their promises denim fetch resigned
themselves to their deaths in a fight
for mosesper and its people both things
turn around when the people of Freetown
arrive to help witnessing their Marshall
being gunned down spurred them into
action after the bike sends to imposing
a nearly indestructible battle droids
into combat fed's allies scatter for
cover fed then leaves a battlefield in
an attempt to bring in reinforcements
leaving din to distract the massive
droids wreaking destruction on the city
it's at this point that pelimoto arrives
and with her grogu who has chosen to
return to den fat returns riding his
Rancor which destroys the droids with
help from DIN and grogu fetz then wins a
duel against Cub Bane ending the battle
grogu connects with a rampaging Rancor
through the force calming the creature
after Shand assassinates the pike
leadership and their backstabbing allies
she and fed to take control of mosespa
meanwhile take to the stars in the
restored M1 Starfighter
as he's being transferred after his
capture moff Gideon escapes New Republic
custody Captain Carson tether of the new
Republic Starfighter core finds a
derelict prison transport blown open
from the outside with remnants of beskar
alloy lodged in the cabin wall that
leads Teva to suspect mandalorians broke
Gideon out of prison it's soon clear the
Stormtroopers are Gideon equipped with
Bhaskar armor are responsible and that
he never faced trial Gideon soon appears
in a meeting with various other Imperial
bigwigs referring to themselves as a
shadow Council Grand Admiral thrawns and
pending return is mentioned by Captain
Gilead pellian while brental hugs father
of the sequel trilogy's Armitage hugs
are loose to his own cloning experiments
these are likely tied to the mission to
resurrect Palpatine
after reuniting with grogu din jarin has
only one priority redeeming himself in
the eyes of his people by bathing in the
Living Waters beneath Mandalore showing
his face to living beings isn't easily
forgiven under the Creed he swore but
the rumors that Mandalore is cursed and
toxic make din's Mission anything but
simple he returns to Navarro which has
become a thriving Hub of trade and
culture under the leadership of high
magistrate to grief kaga din hopes to
recruit a Droid to help him Scout
mandalore's atmosphere and there's only
one Droid that he trusts he hopes to
revive the deactivated ig-11 despite
din's best efforts IG can't be restored
to his former self thankfully he gets a
pinch hitter in the form of R5 D4 the
very same Droid fans may remember from A
New Hope the newly minted Trio says soft
to explore the supposedly cursed Planet
Mandalore then finally Ventures to his
people's ancestral Homeland mandalor has
certainly seen better days the Empire's
brutal bombing left the surface of the
planet devastated and the domed cities
that existed during the Clone Wars are
nothing but Rubble that desolate
appearance doesn't discourage din though
after determining that the air is fine
to breathe he descends into the old
capital of cindari and the mines below
the Empire's bombing rays of woke some
nasty creatures and the Mysterious
mechanical foe captures then along with
the dark saber grogu leaves the planet
with R5 to find help and they bring back
bokeh tan who has been sulking since
losing a chance to take the darksaber
the two mandalorians mend their former
animosity toward one another and Beau
helps then descend into the Living
Waters The Living Waters wind up being
much deeper than expected vertebau is
there once again to help Den out she
also captures a glimpse in the depths of
what appears to be a mythosaur a symbol
of Mandalore thought to be extinct for
ages having dipped in the waters denim
bokotan are officially cleansed by the
terms of the Creed
wild denim bogotana are visiting holy
sites evil grows at the heart of the
Galaxy Dr pen Pershing once the chief
clothing scientist for moff Gideon has
now reformed New Republic citizen thanks
to the galactic government's new amnesty
program Pershing clearly wants to use
his Knowledge and Skills for good but
once again he falls in with the wrong
people Elia Kane another of Gideon's
former subordinates for friends Pershing
and convinces him that she too is
reformed this is all the ruse however
and It ultimately leads to Pershing
being tortured with a mind player this
proves that the imperial Remnant still
has great power and influence in the
galactic core it also demonstrates just
how ineffectual the new Republic has
already become a death star may have
been destroyed but the Galaxy is still
in chaos a new Republic doesn't have
enough soldiers or resources to properly
Patrol the outer rim even on Coruscant
every major initiative is hindered by
bureaucratic red tape
you could submit a c1023 request but
I've never seen someone from the amnesty
program make one of those I'd have to
check if that's even possible then
invoke at Sam return to Denzel covert
after bathing in the Living Waters to
both surprise are both welcomed with
mostly open arms as she hasn't removed
her helmet since her dip in the pool the
freshly strengthened covert bonds during
a mission to rescue past visler's son
Ragnar who's been abducted by a giant
flying Beast Boca Town leads to war
party and learns more about the way soon
Captain tether arrives to ask for help
after being denied back up from the new
republic government but Planet Navarro
has been attacked by Pirates Who are
secretly under orders from moff Gideon
himself after some negotiation the
covert agrees to assist a full
deployment of mandalorians arrives on
Navarro to fight off the invaders no
pirate gang is a match for an organized
and fully equipped Mandalorian Battalion
and the planet is quickly saved din's
covert has finally revealed itself to
the world in broad daylight and Navarro
Embraces them the whole clan is off
would land on the planet where they can
build and live in the open free from the
secrecy they've been confined to for so
long surprisingly the armorer has spoke
a town to remove her helmets and go find
her old Mandalorian group seen a
methosaur in the living Ward says marked
the end of an age the armor SS and the
Clans must be reunited
after helping liberate Navarro DIN grogu
and Boca tan set off to find more
mandalorians to join them the ultimate
goal is assembling an army capable of
reclaiming Mandalore the crew heads to a
small world called plasia 15 where Boze
old mercenary faction is currently
serving as private security but before
being granted an audience with the group
they must first solve a mystery the
planet has been beset by a rash of
strange Droid malfunctions so denim
bogatan are asked to investigate after
visiting a Droid bar and engaging in
surface level discourse about robot
rights the pair finds a culprit plazier
15's out of security he was lingering
loyalty to Count Dooku they earn what
appear to be powerful allies in Blasio
15's aristocracy and they're given Their
audience with the other mandalorians by
the time Boca San and din jarin made
contact with their old platoon they're
not exactly honored guess after failing
to win the darksaber from moff Gideon
Beau lost a respect of her former
colleagues they left her behind with
their Fleet of stolen former Imperial
ships ax woes once a trusted Lieutenant
of Bose is the new leader of the group
ax woes is their leader now he isn't
happy to see her and he challenges
boca's hand to a door both combatants
dig deep into their arsenals in the end
Beau comes out Victorious but she
refuses to kill ax in the traditional
custom she declares that mandalorians
have spent too much time and energy
across history spilling each other's
blood if they are to retake Mandalore
she says they must finally be United the
trouble once again is that bow still
doesn't hold the dark saber thus when
then steps in to explain that he was
defeated by a monster in the old minds
of Mandalore and the bow Katan is the
one who saved him as such possession of
the darksaber transferred to the monster
then to Bo she claims the blade and
ignites it in dramatic fashion bringing
her old Mandalorian cohorts under her
command
Boca town and dinjarin return to the
covert on Navarro along with the
Mandalorian group from Plaza 15. grogu
gets an upgrade in the form of a
palatable IG Droid body and the two very
different Clans try to find common
ground it's a bit tricky at first since
the children of the watch have very
specific views on the Creed and the
others see them as extremists but with a
rousing speech from Beau and the promise
of reclaiming the home world everybody
more or less agrees to get along it is
time to retake our Homeworld the full
Mandalorian Force Journeys to Mandalore
and a small Scout party touches down to
explore the surface and find the great
Forge the nature of the planet's
atmosphere prohibits contact with the
ships in orbit after a bit of a hike the
party encounters a faction of
Mandalorian survivors who have been
living on the planet since the Great
Purge they quickly pledged their
allegiance to Boca turn and help lead
the newcomers to their destination
Mandalore has become a very dangerous
place a giant monster attacks the
survivor's land ship at one point and
the general landscape appears
inhospitable still they make it to the
great Forge only to find a new obstacle
when the party arrives at the forge
they're met by an Elite Squad of
bescar-clad Storm Troopers moth Gideon
has built a secret base adjacent to the
forge itself and he's been using the
myth of Mandalore being cursed as cover
to continue his cloning experiments din
is captured ax wolves flies back to the
fleet for help and pass visler
heroically sacrifices himself to ensure
that the others escape he's killed by a
trio of praetorian guards the elite
Warriors clad in red who were most
recently seen in The Last Jedi Amanda
lorians had previously been living on
the planet take Bowen company to a
hidden cave Hideout where they show
their farming efforts that have been
resuscitating mandalore's natural
ecosystem when ax reaches a command ship
he orders all the other mandalorians
down to the surface as backup he
continues to Pilot the cruiser as a
decoy but grogu's helper din is able to
escape his captives didn't grogu
discovered that Gideon has been
developing clones of himself in hopes of
building a force sensitive super Army
didn't destroys the clones and tracks
down Gideon who has a shiny new suit of
beskarama with help from Bogota den and
grogu defeat Gideon and the praetorian
guards who all burn when ax crashes a
former Imperial cruiser directly into
the base and blows it up using his
grubbing Force Powers grogu protects DIN
and Boca Town from the blast with moth
Gideon finally defeated and is based on
Mandalore destroyed the planet returns
to its rightful inhabitants Boca Town
lights the great Forge and the armorer
begins baptizing young mandalorians in
the Living Waters between the
resurrection of old cultural customs and
the return of mandalore's natural
ecosystem things look bright for the
planet but then and grogu don't stay for
long for grogu to rise from foundling to
Mandalorian Apprentice then decides to
officially adopt him as his son a little
green guy is dubbed DIN grogu and his
new dad vows to take him on adventures
befitting an apprentice back on Navarro
grief karga offersed in a cabin outside
of town where he and grogu can live and
rest between missions ig-11 is
resurrected as the new Marshal of
Navarro and dim becomes a new Republic
contractor more the duo Saga is far from
over they've definitely reached an
ending of sorts Mandalore has been
retaken grogu is no longer a foundling
and dinner's been officially recognized
as a Force for good in the galaxy
[Music]